exercice très intéressant aujourd'hui je
suis là pour vous parler d'une telle ées
une telle ées connectés de la marque
m mais tu sais pas si vous connaissez
lettre c'est une marque allemande et qui
fabrique des télés jusque là c'est très
bien et donc aujourd'hui je vous parlais
d'un modèle super cool parce qu'ils
coûtent 509 euros
on a une télé avec un écran de 58 pouces
de là à
de là à peu près pas facile à bien comme
ça 58 pouces c'est très grand qu'est ce
qu'on a à ce tarif là chez meys à 509
euros
qu'est ce que cette télé peut faire
qu'est-ce qu'elle ne peut pas faire
quels sont les avantages parce qu'elle
est faite pour vous quelles sont
également les limites parce que vous en
douterez à 509 euros
on peut pas tout avoir néanmoins on a
une solution qui se tient qui est
intéressant qui est très courte une télé
connectée
je vais tout vous expliquer tout vous
détailler comme ça vous allez tout
savoir sur ce modèle là et bien
évidemment si elle vous intéresse pour
trouver le lien en bas dans la
description c'est pas hyper hyper
évident à filmer comme ça dans le studio
mais on va quand même réussi à
l'exercice premier truc qui est
vachement intéressant c'est qu'elle est
quand même assez fine on a débord qui
sont quand même tous faim tout fin elle
est bien profilée avec des pieds qui
l'assuré lève donc tout ça donne un côté
très léger la marque qui est située la
hausse entre le deuxième pied qui situe
de l'autre côté parce que bien
évidemment il faut deux pieds on a des
petits plastique qui viennent se visser
2006 yves de vis ici rien de bien
compliqué on a toutes les connectiques
il vient de se loger ici avait une prise
antenne usb 3.0 usb 2.0 on a 3 hdmi hdmi
2.0 hdmi 1.4 sortie optique prise
ethernet et la prise pour l'alim et de
l'autre côté il ya un truc à savoir
c'est que souvent les télés ça va être
du 5 ans 1 pouces avec du 65 pouces 75
pouces 58 pouces est pas un format qu'on
a trop l'habitude de voir moi je trouve
ça pas mal j'aime bien en avoir un peu
plus sans avoir trop chez moi 55 pouces
c'est la meilleure taille 65 pouces
c'est un petit peu avoue quand même
avoir beaucoup de recul avoir une très
belle pièce 1 58 pouces jeu peut loger
chez moi ça permet d'avoir un écran un
peu plus grand qu'un 55 c'est très
logique ce que je dis mais je vous
assure
autant d'expériences apporte quelque
chose le fait de venir un peu tiré la
diagonale c'est assez fille qu ici on a
un écran 4 ko hd 3840 par 2160 pixels
un grand classique mais surtout ici on
à une dalle lcd c'est du direct l'aisne
c'est plutôt bien réussi je vous mets un
programme de démo pour se rendre compte
un peu des couleurs là ont effectivement
image qui est hyper bien calibré avec un
contenu qui est directement intégré à la
télé moi ce qui va m'intéresser avec un
téléviseur comme ça c'est l'expérience
est ici vous avez une android tv android
9 si vous connaissez les androïdes télé
ne pas vous apprendre grand chose mais
si vous connaissez pas vous allez voir
l'expérience est vraiment bien vous
venez naviguer dans votre android vous
avez des applications vous pouvez
télécharger sur votre place tout comme
vous le feriez sur un smartphone android
c'est intrigant classique vous avez
plein d'applis des applis y en a
énormément que ce soit mal canal clean
molotov rakuten où je voulais passe très
très très rapidement vous avez un
catalogue de dingue pour pouvoir
regarder du contenu comme ça en france
tv cbs news si vous le souhaitez vous
avez également des jeux vous r3 bien
évidemment netflix youtube bien
évidemment prend une vidéo si vous le
souhaitez si vous prenez un abonnement
tout le catalogue de google
vous allez donc avoir une expérience
100% personnalisés il faut vous créez un
compte google jusque là montré classique
votre télé elle se connecte directement
au wifi de votre maison
en plus de ça vous avez 16 giga de
stockage pour toutes vos applications et
tout votre contenu vous allez venir
télécharger directement dans votre
télémètre aura aucune corriger si on va
se faire le test de ce smartphone là
c'est le web +8 et vous avez deux haut
parleurs de 10 watts qui vont travailler
ensemble pour vous apporter une
expérience stéréo qui est somme toute
correct je voulais montrer une
télécommande qui est assez sympa très
complète qui a coté un peu premium avec
ce côté un peu marronner bouton pour
l'allumer pour éteindre le mieux très
classique vous allez avoir notamment le
bouton netflix et prennent vidéos qui
sont embarqués tous les deux plutôt bien
volume monte le son elle est assez
complète très complète d'ailleurs donc
vous allez pouvoir venir gratter dans
tout ce que vous voulez on va retrouver
un dos plastique quelque chose de très
efficace
et comme on a ici une androïde télé on
peut venir castet du contenu parce qu'on
a à chrome caste intégré ça c'est très
cool je vous montre par exemple je lance
une vidéo sur mon smartphone sur youtube
hop je clique je vais castet que je
tourne sur un os ou bien évidemment sur
android vous pouvez faire depuis un
smartphone depuis un pc depuis un hack
depuis une tablette
et si vous êtes un peu à l'ancienne avec
du contenu sur votre clé usb pour
la branche est derrière pour venir
montrer vos photos ou alors un film que
vous avez réalisé depuis votre caméra
pourquoi pas en tout cas si vous voulez
vous pouvez le faire elle est compatible
dolby vision dolby audio dts trousses
hollande hdr 10 et vous pouvez même
connecter un casque sans fil grâce au
bluetooth 5.0 vous avez un petit menu
dans votre télé qui vous permettra de
venir choisir dans différents modes mode
d'image alors globalement je vois pas
grande grande grande différence entre le
mojo qui à venir ternir un poil plus
utilisateur sport standard un mode audio
standard musique sport film bon une fois
de plus ça va pas vraiment venir
révolutionner l'histoire là dessus et
peut également venir choisir votre
source analogique terrestre quatre
satellites avaient et ensuite vos 3 j ai
mis une fois de plus en fonction ce que
vous allez venir brancher sur votre
téléviseur quelques petits paramètres
choisir votre réseau sélectionnez vos
entrées votre compte pour vous connecter
vos applications n'y a pas grand grand
grandes possibilités parce qu'ici l'idée
c'est qu'on met vraiment s'appuyer sur
l'expérience d'android tv je sais une
télé c'est mieux pouvoir la regarder
directement pour s'en rendre compte
c'est compliqué au travers d'une vidéo
youtube pour pouvoir se faire un avis -
dans l'expérience globale
j'aime bien l'idée de l'écran des
cuisses dago net de 58 pouces ses plus
grands plus immersif en taille d'écran
éventail de meubles aussi pour vraiment
tenir compte
on est vraiment dans l'intermédiation se
rapproche plus à mon sens dans 55 que
dans 65 la qualité de la dalle en
elle-même est pas mal vous la connecter
très facilement l'expérience android tv
est très cool
la télécommande est très complète on
peut même se demander par moments c'est
quelque part un peu trop complète
est ce que vous allez utiliser tout ça
et bien je suis pas sûr mais en tout cas
si vous souhaitez le faire vous pouvez
le faire c'est un grand classique par
rapport à ce qu'on trouve dans l'univers
des télécommandes
vous avez en plus votre google assistant
vous pouvez venir parler à google très
facilement
quelle heure est il il est 16 heures 22
voyez c'est extrêmement pratique donc on
a une expérience globale qui est bonne
on a une dalle qui est grande et surtout
le tarif sera mini donc si vous levez
plaisir avec une télé allemande
mexes et bien vous avez une fois de plus
le lien dans la description c'est
vraiment une découverte une marque que
je connais pas ce que j'avais déjà vu
sur différents salons je vais pas eu
l'occasion de les tester donc c'est une
chose faite en tout cas avec ce modèle
là et une fois de plus si vous avez un
budget aux alentours de 500 euros eh
bien écoutez je pense que ça peut être
une bonne acquisition dans l'univers des
télés connectées android a vous de me
dire vous ce que vous
en pensez en bas en commentaire est ce
que vous connaissez cette marque est ce
qu'elle peut vous tentez est-ce que ce
modèle là pour vous plaire et qu'est ce
que vous pensez qu est ce que vous
pensez à l'idée d'avoir un écran avec
une diagonale de 58 pouces au lieu de 55
pouces
mark et moi tout ça en bas en
commentaire quant à nous on trouve
extrêmement rapidement pour continuer à
parler peut-être parce que oui vous avez
vu c'est assez incroyable tellement de
choses en ce moment pour on ne s'en est
pas mais surtout beaucoup d'amour rizhao
[Musique]
on
en
enfin